[Music]
all right the president now is reacting
to a flood of information coming out
about how the deep state targeted and in
fact spied on his campaign on Twitter
earlier today he wrote look out things
have turned around on the criminal deep
state they go after phony collusion with
Russia and a made-up scam and end up
getting caught in a major spy scandal
the likes of which this country may have
never seen before what goes around comes
around we've been saying that did we
call this the year of the boomerang it's
exactly what this is you have a criminal
deep state and it's all coming out at
breakneck speed now it's literally hour
by hour the things that we're learning
it's new and it's damning the details
are unbelievable the president slamming
the entire scandal and giving it a new
nickname this is the tip of the iceberg
take a look we now call it spy gate
you're calling it spy gate a lot of bad
things have happened I want them all to
get together they'll sit in the room
hopefully they'll be able to work it out
among themselves now because new
information is coming out at a
rapid-fire pace deep state actors like
the arrogant sanctimonious James Comey
they are racing to try and cover their
tracks
now Comey fired off a pair of tweets
this morning facts matter the FBI's use
of confidential human sources the actual
term we call them spies is tightly
regulated and essential to protecting
the country attacks on the FBI and lying
about its work will do lasting damage to
the country how will Republicans explain
this to their grandchildren well here's
a better idea Jim how will you explain
what you did to your grandchildren and
you have to love how Comey is using an
FBI official jargon confidential human
sources to try and spin this did you
have a spy in the Clinton campaign did
you have a spy in that campaign he
continues dangerous time when our
country is led by those who will lie
about anything back by those who will
believe anything based on information
from media sources that will say
anything Americans must break out of
that bubble and seek truth all right
speaking of line that's exactly what
Comey did under oath in front of
Congress when he falsely claimed
he didn't decide to exonerate Hillary
Clinton before interviewing her and 17
other key witnesses they were writing at
months before and you know why because
Comey is corrupt thank God the president
fired him and he can't keep his big
mouth shut
we advise to me as the right to remain
silent and the president is right to
fire back at the disgraced former FBI
director let's take a look at what he
said I think James Comey 'he's got a lot
of problems if you look at what he did
if you look at all of the lies the
tremendous lies if you look at all
that's going on I think James Comey has
got a lot of problems now at some point
they have an IG report and then let's
see what James Comey has to say but I
assume he's covered in the IG report but
if you look at what he said all of the
lies all of the fiction I think he's got
a lot of problems I did a great service
to this country by firing James Comey
and excuse me a lot of people have said
it and you go into the FBI and a lot of
those great people working in the FBI
they will tell you I did a great service
to our country my FBI friends tell me
that every day and they are helping to
expose the corruption and their agency
they want the truth out because it's not
rank and file so the soon-to-be-released
DOJ IG report is supposed to hammer
commis corrupt handling of the Clinton
email investigation we know it was
rigged
we know Clinton committed felonies and
crimes and obstructed justice and Comey
and his buddies and struck to put the
fix in to save Hillary's campaign then
they quickly started spying on the Trump
campaign where's the warrant where's the
justification
now commis deep state buddy former Obama
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper he is now in a panic watching to
try and save himself now he's running
from liberal media outlet to liberal
media outlet promoting his new book just
like James Comey did and trying to spin
what is a false narrative take a look
what he said with the ladies on the view
I asked you was the FBI spying on
Trump's campaign no they were not they
were spying on a term I don't
particularly like but on what the
Russians were doing trying to understand
were the Russians infiltrating trying to
gain access trying to gain leverage and
influence what they do so why doesn't he
like that he should be happy there
should be really the president should be
happy the Obama administration and
people in the FBI were spying on his
campaign without a warrant that we know
of and then the FISA warrant they lied
to poor judges is that not the deep
state trying to destroy his candidacy
now presidency and at this point clapper
is just he's straight-up delusional the
president good for him he's not letting
these lies slide either he's taking them
head-on
when they look at the documents I think
people are gonna see a lot of bad things
happen I hope it's not so because if it
is has never been anything like it in
the history of our country
I hope I mean if you look at clapper he
sort of admitted that they had spies in
the campaign
yesterday inadvertently but I hope it's
not true but it looks like it is this is
the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in this country's history it
shows you just how pretentious how eager
testicle people like clapper and call me
really are now they don't see that the
crossfire hurricane well it's now coming
their way
the wind has shifted the direction and
like we have been warning they both have
the right to remain silent
apparently not listening to me now what
comer and clappy clapper have done
clappy here is orchestrate a massive
abuse of power the biggest in American
political history look at investigative
journalist cheryl atkinson out with
another great article eight signs
pointing to a counterintelligence
operation that was deployed against
trump's campaign here they are codenamed
the FBI had one crossfire hurricane from
jumping jack flash of the stones which
is the operation where they spied on the
Trump campaign wiretap fever cheryl
atkinson is pointing out how seventh
rumpus o shi'ites were caught up in this
surveillance web you also have the
massive abuse of power FISA abuse lying
to FISA judges on four occasions
spying on Carter page using a Clinton
bought and paid for
see a not telling of course the judges
in that case never verified never
corroborating National Security Letters
the FBI bypassing all judicial approval
to obtain phone records by using these
National Security Letters in other words
the power of our intelligence community
we saw the unmasking a dramatic 350
percent increase from key Obama
officials Wow
magically in the 22nd 2016 election year
changing the rules remember in December
of 2016
clapper making it easier to share
intelligence across all these government
agencies that helps them cover media
strategy clapper Brennan both regulars
in the liberal media clapper reportedly
leaking details about this phony bought
and paid for Russian dossier to fake
News CNN where he now works and is paid
leaking anonymous sources they have been
running too friendly outlets to
selectively put out information all
designed to propagandize and lie to the
American people and damage president
Trump and Friends and Foreman snoops the
FBI had this informant maybe others
spying on the Trump campaign Comey had
his friend leaking to the New York Times
to get a special counsel which by the
way that probably was illegal and the
bureau working with former British spy
in other words Oh a foreign operative
Christopher Steele he put together this
Clinton bought and paid for dossier the
evidence of wrongdoing is overwhelming
it is incontrovertible not to mention as
we told you last night when Sarah Carter
Carter further explained the FBI's
timeline is now collapsing and the
investigations not adding up former
Obama AG Loretta Lynch telling Congress
at the FBI the DOJ officials were
discussing Trump campaign associate
Carter page in spring of last year maybe
that would have been a good time to go
say mr. candidate mr. Trump I want you
to watch there might be some people that
we're have an eye on remember Trump said
the most excoriating he said to Comey
was is anyone around my camp happy I
want you to you know I want you to do
your job and we've been told the
investigation officially
started in july with george papadapolis
so this timeline is way off it's going
to the spring of 2016 which is why
Congress needs to now see all the
documents attorney General Sessions I
hope you're watching tonight also
Judicial Watch learning that the FBI
will order Trump aiding FBI lovebirds
struck in Page to preserve agency
records on their personal accounts and
on their personal devices if they
haven't already acid-wash them and
according to Judicial Watch earlier this
week a judge ordered the FBI to start
processing thirteen thousand pages of
previously undisclosed emails between
struck and page we can only imagine what
are in those text messages and emails
seeing how they trashed Trump constantly
in their text messages and struck at the
center of all of this and then you have
senator Grassley he's raising a red flag
and a very disturbing message from
struck end page that actually suggests
the White House of Obama is running this
meaning the Obama administration now
it's unclear what investigation
specifically they're referring to which
is why everything needs to be unredacted
but they did talk an awful lot about
Trump and another top story tonight is
absolutely stunning Carrie Pinkett she's
at the Daily Caller reporting several
FBI agents want to be subpoenaed by
Congress so they can finally expose all
the misconduct and corruption under call
me and of course Andrew McCabe now these
FBI agents they're also saying that they
want to see McCain prosecuted since he
lied on to old three times for the
inspector general one that what general
Flynn was accused of oh and by the way
we know that nobody in the FBI thought
he lied this is why we always say it's
the upper echelon here at the FBI in the
intelligence community the DOJ who are
the deep state actors not rank and file
they're helping us get to the truth and
if it wasn't for these people the FBI we
wouldn't know the truth in the end they
are serving our country with honor and
dignity and integrity and respect they
are ashamed of what their former bosses
did and furious about what has happened
that's why it is so important for all of
us to get the truth release the
documents also tonight it's put
shut up time for rod Rosenstein the king
of slow walking stonewalling and
obstruction Republican Committee Chair
Devin Nunez trey Gowdy they're set to be
tomorrow with top FBI DOJ intelligence
officials about the documents they have
been requesting forever to see and I got
to tell you given Rosen Steve's track
record there's no way he's going to hand
everything over it's only gonna be a
briefing and here's why
rod Rosenstein he wants to be able to
control the flow of information just
like he's been doing from the get-go
begging Paul Ryan oh don't release the
information about FISA abuse remember
Sarah Carter reporting information that
Congress is trying to see will hold the
keys to all of this spying on the Trump
campaign rod Rosenstein has more
problems than just stonewalling tonight
look at what law professor Steve
Calabresi is now arguing the rod Rosen
Stein's appointment of Robert Muller is
in fact unconstitutional as the great
one Mark Levin said last night he cites
the majority opinion in Morrissey versus
Olson now the basic problem being that
Muller is more powerful than all 96 US
Attorney's Muller was also never
nominated never confirmed by the US
Senate and because Robert Muller's
appointment is unconstitutional and that
renders everything that he has done
since May 17 2017 null and void and
that's why we heard just a couple of
Fridays ago judge TS Ellis the third
demanding to see Rod Rosenstein scope
memo that gave Muller the ability
supposedly to carry out this witch-hunt
now judge Ellis just eviscerate 'add
Muller's team and his pit bull Andrew
Weissman for going after Paul Manafort
on a 2005 tax fraud allegation that has
nothing to do with Russia and he called
out Muller for putting the screws the
judges words to man afford why to get
him to sing
remember singers can also compose and
flip on Trump so they can prosecute or
impeach him and as far as Rod Rosenstein
goes the Bannen says Rosenstein could in
fact be fired and very soon we'll have
to wait and see what that's all about
also tonight take a look at this
headline from the American Center for
Law and
it was a favor factory deep state forced
to turn over thousands of clinton-era
State Department emails to about the
Clinton Foundation debunking supposed
firewall at the aclj reporting that the
State Department will be turning over
nearly 30,000 emails between Hillary
Clinton's State Department and her
Family Foundation this is why he keeps
saying I know it takes more time than
you want where I'm peeling layers of an
onion and that means they were in
constant communication and as the AP
discovered in 2016 more than half of
these people who met with the Clintons
while she was serving as Secretary of
State ended up either personally or
through an organization giving money and
funneling it back to the Clinton
Foundation and another major development
tonight clock is ticking for the DOJ and
the FBI to hand over documents to the
Senate Judiciary Committee Chair Chuck
Grassley about this highly suspicious
case of Michael Flynn a man who served
this country for over 30 years
Grassley wants to see the documents
related to Flynn's FBI interview as
James Comey told Congress the FBI agents
who talked to Flynn they didn't think he
lied so why did Robert Muller charge
general Flynn with lying in the first
place and also tonight President Trump
revealing new details about his
potential June 12 summit with a little
Rocketman Fox and Friends co-host our
own Brian Kilmeade spoke with the
president earlier today out on Long
Island after his roundtable on ms-13
gang violence take a look June 12th are
you going to be in Singapore we'll see
what happens I mean right now we're
looking at it we're talking about it and
they're talking to us we have certain
conditions we'll see what happens but
there's a good chance and it would be a
great thing for North Korea if that
happens it'll be a great thing for North
Korea most importantly it would be a
great thing for the world so we'll see
what happens right right don't miss the
full interview tomorrow starting 6 a.m.
Fox and Friends